foreign
Ukraine has become a devastating War of
Attrition where the big guns are king
and that is now a pressing issue as NATO
countries meet because their supplies of
Munitions can't keep up with Ukraine's
demand
when it comes to artillery we need
ammunition we need spare parts we need
maintenance we need all the logistics to
ensure that we are able to sustain these
weapon systems so it's not only about
discussing new systems but ensuring that
all the existing systems are working as
they should Ukraine's defense minister
was making it clear what he wants from
NATO his forces need ammunition from the
west and a lot more of it not since
World War II and battles like Monte
Casino have so many artillery rounds
being fired in a conflict as we're now
witnessing in Ukraine Ukrainian forces
are thought to be getting through an
average 5 000 shells a day funny exact
data about Munitions is next to
Impossible Britain isn't the only
country that closely guards that kind of
classified information but what this war
is proving is that NATO countries have
not been stockpiling nearly enough
ammunition for years
analysts say it's now clear as supplies
currently stand NATO would be
hard-pressed fighting its own war
against Russia let alone supplying
Ukraine's there's a lot of open
reporting in the U.S about how long it's
taken to spin up production production
lines some of which were dormant and
some of which weren't working 24 7. now
the Pentagon have put a lot of effort
into it as has General Austin the U.S
defense secretary but it's far from
clear to me that defense industry across
NATO is as fully mobilized as it might
be so this is a wake-up call I think so
yes Western arm suppliers are ramping up
production to try and meet Ukrainian
demand but Russia is too as it
militarizes its economy
we know that they have ramped up
production on their assembly lines
especially ammunition and armored
vehicle production they are essentially
taking out loads of vehicles out of
storage reconditioning them upgrading
them with whatever they can Source
um they are basically moving to a more
longer term War footing
the walls becoming a race to supply more
and more weapons and Munitions that will
only intensify with both sides expected
to launch massive new offensives as
winter draws to a close Dominic wagorn
Sky News